riche
veut
beaucoup
un de avec
un
la la
sel
salez-le
tremper
SUIS
la
saler un frin puor
sel
fille brune aux yeux de reine
la bouche la plus douce de toutes
la ville a laissé un riche prétendant et
décent aïe
Juana quoi
barbarie
la petite Marila, celle aux cheveux courts, celle qui
tout le monde dit que quelque chose de spécial se produit
tous les soirs et entre rires et bche les deux
Ils disent qu'ils vont à la mer
drogue
marijuana qu'ils recherchent
félicité
Maruana
Maruana cherche le
félicité
les deux filles disent qu'elles veulent se marier
pour officialiser ton problème
que se cacher nous rappelle un autre
des gens qui, même s'ils sont normaux, non non
ils jouent toujours un scénario juridique
les lumières s'allument et il y a du monde
applaudissez et les autres s'ils sont partis
tu portes les choses qui font mal, Dieu saint
quelle barbarie
dans
marijuana
de la marijuana ou
marijuana qu'ils recherchent
félicité
marijuana, dis-le
drogue
marijuana qu'ils recherchent
bonheur mille couleurs dans le ciel bébé
Comment ça change
Le temps, comment veux-tu qu'ils te connaissent bébé
qu'est-ce qui va
passer quoi
Cela arrivera si à la fin nous partons
au paradis et à la fin le temps va
je finis mieux chaque fois que je dis
Je veux que mille choses pires suivent
installer
drogue
la marijuana cherche le
félicité
marijuana, qu'est-ce que ça dit
marijuana qui va
marijuana Recherchez le
le bonheur c'est notre
Lieu C'est là
nous
dormir et ici nous cessons de
prie pourquoi pas plus
nous
est-ce que tu
rappel
Une nuit de retour
En juin, nous avons perdu les mots sur le chemin du retour
la maison était un
bien
était Ne me juge pas ce que nous devenons
Non
souviens-toi, ne m'approche pas pour l'avoir dit
mensonges
nous, j'essaie d'écouter les chansons que tu as dites
ch ma vie mais je me suis endormi avec
faire
a donné
de
Nous ne sommes pas au paradis en enfer mais je le suis
fermer nous
W Ceci est notre
lieu
ici nous le ferons
AB avec gra on l'appelle
à
prendre
Oh
et
J'ai
Oh
rite
spiritus
Montagne
aller
Rora
scie
p
Q
po
cadre
zéa
fra
spiritus
Esprit
Nous
il
PS sans éducation c'est pays sans
l'évolution
sem la
violence
avec
parous
vérifier
solidarité PE en nous
chanter Merci maman en nous respectant en
nous
nettoyer l'esprit
pe pe solidarité pe
ils sont nuls
nous
nous pe fa nous sembler J la pe ou maman
J la pé J la pé J
le J
tour J
la J la pe J la pe J la pe J la pe J
laap J la pe di la pe J
le J
pru gr
maman
Domsa Rnu
domu
non, je viens de
tellement de choses cachées
mo
de temps en temps, allez à
tonas vas-y
algues Embora DME
pour
Volta
barul au repos
ouvre-nous
escur
purée
repentir D
dans
loin
ne pas ressentir d'amour
tellement
vous
Yo
Les enfants sont différents
aujourd'hui j'entends chaque mère
dis que maman a besoin de quelque chose aujourd'hui pour se calmer
son
en bas et même si elle n'est pas vraiment malade
elle prend une petite pilule jaune
courir vers l'abri de Mars Little
l'aider et l'aider sur son chemin à la chercher
elle est occupée
jour
enfants
aujourd'hui j'entends maman
dit de cuisiner des aliments frais pour ses maris
juste pour
Dve et elle achète un gâteau instantané et elle
la brûle gelée
Steak Elle court vers le refuge
de pour la petite aide de maman et ça
l'aide à avancer
son
docteur
Jouez encore un peu
l'extérieur le
porte qu'elle a prise pour
plus le
TR devient
là
Homme, c'est pareil
aujourd'hui, j'entends toutes les mères dire qu'elles
Non
J'apprécie que vous
y arriver si difficilement
satisfaire tu peux calmer ton
Attention, allez courir à l'abri d'un
la petite aide de maman et pour t'avoir aidé
pour aider à minimiser
votre médecin
ça fait encore plaisir
de
dehors, elle a pris pour
plus le
Dr Love, juste beaucoup à faire
aujourd'hui, j'entends chaque mère dire le
la recherche du bonheur semble juste
a et si vous en prenez plus, vous le ferez
obtenir
et ne plus courir pour se mettre à l'abri d'un
la petite aide de la mère, ils aident juste
tu es en route vers ta mort occupée
jour
encore un peu de
l'extérieur
à Elle a pris pour
plus
obtenir
pour